la décentralisation est au cœur du
projet politique de l'UMP c'est nous qui
avons inscrit dans la Constitution la
République
décentralisée la proximité la
responsabilité ce sont des valeurs pour
nous l'homme est libre responsable dans
son territoire lui aussi le territoire
doit être libre et responsable c'est
pour ça que nous voulons une
décentralisation qui libère les énergies
mais aussi une décentralisation
financièrement responsable on ne peut
pas accepter que certaines régions multi
les dépenses de fonctionnement quand
l'État lui de l'autre côté fait des
efforts de bonne gestion il faut donc
être libre et responsable pour la
personne comme pour les collectivités
territoriales dans la décentralisation
la question des ressources est
fondamental nous voulons que les
collectivités territoriales et les
moyens de leur projet mais pour ça il
faut protéger la relation de sincérité
entre les financements de l'État et ce
des collectivités territoriales mais
aussi l'autonomie financière nous
l'avons inscrite dans la Constitution et
puis nous voulons de la justice
territoriale c'est au cœur aussi du
projet UMP pour que les territoires les
plus fragiles la ruralité les zones de
montagne et toutes ces villes qui
connaissent des difficultés aujourd'hui
de gestion que les territoires les plus
fragiles par la péréquation bénéficie de
la solidarité des territoires les plus
riches il faut donc dans cette crise
mondiale européenne mais aussi française
défend de nos convictions le territoire
est un espace républicain de liberté et
de
responsabilité